got breaking news here this is a sports
betting case has a decision from the
Supreme Court Third Circuit is reversed
a 7 to 2 decision for New Jersey and
sports betting so the US Supreme Court
rules that federal ban on state
sanctioned sports betting is
unconstitutional decides case in favor
of New Jersey floodgates now officially
open for other states to allow sports
betting Andrew Brent works for the mm QB
and this is right in his wheelhouse
break this down for me Andrew I Dan I
sat in that courtroom on December 4th
and it's hard to read tea leaves on any
of this but it did seem like this was
going to be a win for New Jersey the
justices were very strident with the
league's representative you know Paul
Clement representing NFL NBA NCAA etc
and seem to be sympathetic with New
Jersey that this is a states rights
issue and the government cannot
legislate something like this so he's
turning it over to the states and it's
going to allow New Jersey to immediately
open their sports books Monmouth Park is
ready to go and there are other states
lined up for an opinion like this to get
it going and my first reaction Dan is I
don't know if the NFL NBA Major League
Baseball hockey are happy they lost or
said they lost because as we've talked
for years there's an inevitability to
this which is now reaching reality well
I also think that they just wanted to
know what is their piece of the pie and
I think that you could say well we don't
want gambling but if it's coming we want
to make sure we're going to make our
money so how do you think this plays out
let's say this upcoming NFL season how
do you think that this now what's this
mean well now definitely New Jersey is
going to have sports books and sports
gambling and books like the Nevada style
sports books that's going to be in the
casinos and the racetracks around New
Jersey I think other states will jump in
before that I think in some ways
look at this and you go oh my god this
is going to be a free-for-all
what can states do or not do and I think
like you said the NFL and NBA etc
probably preferred a legislative result
on this where Congress would make a
federal law rather than the courts
striking down a previous antiquated law
to allow gambling to come out but I
think if we're trying to look at the
glass and is rosy through rose-colored
glasses I think what we're going to see
is that it's going to be legal it's
going to be out there it's going to be
regulated and yes the NFL the NBA
they're trying to get something called
an integrity fee which to me I roll my
eyes because the reason we haven't had
game playing is because of indecorous
but they're trying to get some take out
of this and now dan the negotiations
begin what can we get what can we come
out of this it's gonna be a rollicking
summer between all these leagues
especially the NFL and the states and
the states may just say no why should we
give you money when we can regulate it
and this is gonna be an interesting part
of this so you think some could could
you see where you know the Giants and
Jets play in Jersey it can they where
can they set something up could they
have a betting lounge at the Giants jets
facility and I got I'm just trying to
figure out does it have to be at a
casino for this to happen or can you do
something well you said Monmouth Park so
that's a racetrack but yeah I mean I
don't think there's any limit to where
you establish the sports books but we're
getting a lot of other parties involved
here I mean we got gaming boards we got
legislative state legislators we got
figuring out where this handle is going
to go if there's going to be taxes
it's going to I mean I think the bottom
line is we now have a regulated activity
about to enter the mainstream and where
do the regulator's go one thing is that
NFL's quietly invested in sport radar a
couple years ago they
our gambling Integrity Unit they noticed
mostly in Europe when a bet goes crazy
so they can get in front of it so I
think the concern back to that word the
mantra is integrity can we control it
and is the fact it's going to be in the
light rather than the darkness going to
be a good thing for everyone
Andrew thank you I know you'll be
following it and we'll follow up with
you thank you for joining us I was a
pleasure Dan at saw Andrew Brent
columnist for the mm QB of the athletic
and host of business of sports podcast
there for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]